the Joe Rogan experience it now at 26
but how much time do you think you need
between now and when you have your first
time I may fight you know what is my
dream yes now is now I beat everybody so
like I'm getting bored in the in
kickboxing you know I still defending my
my title because I like it because of
the cash price also and my dream is I
still in contract in for one one young
heart a little bit more than one year
my dream is prepare myself to MMA during
one year so I still got time and after
the end of the contract directly go to
UFC and take the champ for Derrick title
shot all a top five ranked guy I really
I really really would like to fight Nate
Diaz aw and Tony Perry's for from of my
first fight MMA - why - to shock only to
shock the world to show everybody that a
guy who come from kickboxing directly
his first fight is against top guy in
MMA and he he [ __ ] him up that's what I
want to do and I really really believe
in me and I know I will I can and I will
do it now have you been in talks with
the UFC does UFC know about your plan
not yet not yet what they do now but I
think after this show now they're gonna
know yeah so your training at aka was
that the first time you ever trained up
there you know it's my second time
second time when did you train before
before was one years ago November yeah I
came here after my glory fight I broke
my ribs so I took a little bit vacation
in Thailand and then after that yeah I
just fight - a case on Z and yeah I meet
I met everybody DC
Kabhi wasn't there but I met a lot of
great great teammate the the westering
level is just amazing there so I made
have also I mean Xavier Mendes yeah so
that's a great camp for a guy like
YouTube because it's very wrestling have
yeah yeah that's that's what I that's
what I like yeah I want to train you
know what did I say to meet you in front
I say I want to train wrestling because
he like I want to be a world world
champion of wrestling you know I just
wanted to think resting like a
restaurant I don't just want to train my
takedown defense or [ __ ] like that no I
joined I want people to be afraid of me
and on the ground you know I learned
fast as I really like it I think that's
the liver I wanna get and how is it
going when you train it Aki are you
hanging in there like do you find it
uncomfortable of course as a striker in
straighting yeah my level is higher than
anybody else in a key but in the ground
yeah and they're [ __ ] [ __ ] strong
yeah everybody did the iTap everybody
everyday I top him again yeah yeah for
the moment and yeah they say I learned
you have plans on tap yeah of course yes
for the moment I tap and because I'm
learning and this I learned very very
very fast like they show me once and
then I get it you know five minutes
later I get it and so I feel very
confident for the future in me and I
think I wouldn't do it well I'm hoping
you do it's always exciting to see world
champions
and it's particularly kickboxing make
that way to MMA to the UFC and forgot
like you it's a perfect thing because
you're so young because you know six and
you're already a very accomplished world
champion that's right and yeah I think
I'm thinking about Israel Addison yeah
you know mm-hmm
he he he Anita I couldn't do it you know
but he was very smart
yeah Israel the way he planned it
he really worked on his takedown defense
and made sure that he by the time he
made it to the UFC he was already at an
elite level yeah he wasn't elite but he
got a title shot in in glory and he lost
and after that he went to USA you know
so that's what I want to do I want to be
the only one to to be able to yeah to do
that you know and glory kickboxing champ
and then UFC champ
he fought wellness right witness yeah
yeah very close fight it was very cool I
thought he won some people tell you yeah
and some know yeah but Jason wellness is
a leak the lead of well glory is like so
exciting I'm such a fan I love watching
it man it's like one of my favorite
things to watch yes uh it drives me
crazy that it's not popular and and I
was very excited when it was on Spike TV
in America it was they were making a big
deal out of it it looked like they were
gonna you know try to promote it as much
as possible and they tried it for a
little while well then they stopped and
now it's on ESPN a little bit it's on
UFC fight pass which is great I think
that the country will grow is very most
polarizing Colin mm-hmm I think yeah
your friend is so so popular you know
yes some people recognize me in the
street when I haven't friends yet
because of growing is very popular in
Europe